the remake of the original Witcher is
making at least one massive departure
from its source it'll be open world a
feature that didn't come to the
franchise until 2015's The Witcher 3
which is getting a Next Gen update on
December 14th codenamed khanas Majoris
and developed by third-party Studio
Fool's Theory the Remake will be built
from the ground up in Unreal Engine 5
with former CD projekt Red developers
working on the project the news that the
game will be open world came as a part
of the publisher CD Project's most
recent earnings report both the original
Witcher and its sequel Assassin of Kings
featured large open zones players could
explore however progressing the story
past certain key points would move
players to a new Zone closing off the
previous area entirely on top of Karnes
Majoris two other Witcher projects are
currently in development Polaris and
Sirius Sirius has been described as an
innovative of take on the series that is
aimed at both veteran fans and people
new to the franchise currently in
pre-production it is being developed by
Flame in the flood developer the
Molasses Flood and has 60 plus people of
involved in its creation project Polaris
is described as a story-driven open
world RPG built on the legacy of The
Witcher 3 wild Hunt and has more than
150 people working on it at CV project
red this game will be the start of a new
Witcher Trilogy that is aiming to be
delivered within a six-year period
following the Polaris release from
fantasy monster slaying to sci-fi
monster slaying developer off-world
Industries has revealed Starship
Troopers extermination a new game based
on the cult classic 1997 sci-fi film
extermination will recruit you into the
deep space Vanguard an elite Special
Forces Group within the mobile infantry
that has been sent to deal with a
particularly deadly bug Outbreak on the
plant of valaka once on the ground
rounds 12 players will form up into four
squads and will begin working on
Gathering resources building a base
establishing defenses and Exterminating
every bug in sight remember the only
good bug is a dead bug three playable
classes assault support and defense will
be available from launch and a
progression system will allow for new
weapons equipment and perks for each
class to be gradually unlocked the game
will launch first on PC via steam Early
Access in 2023 2023 will also hopefully
see the release of the long-awaited next
title from Rocksteady the developers of
the Batman Arkham games the team is
currently working on another game based
on DC Comics characters Suicide Squad
kill the Justice League and it sounds
like that game along with others will be
a bigger part of a new DCU helmed by
filmmaker James Gunn following the
announcement of guns appointment as
co-chairman of DC Studios along with
movie producer Peter Safran Warner
Brothers Discovery CEO David zazlev
stated that the Duo's new DC Universe
would span across quote live-action
films TV animation and gaming now Gunn
has confirmed as much in response to
questions asked of him on Twitter Gunn
is no stranger to video games either he
wrote the suda 51 video game Lollipop
Chainsaw previously mentioned developer
rocksteady's first Batman game Arkham
Asylum began a rock steady but total
shift from tie-ins for comic book movie
games to Standalone experiences that
weren't created simply to hit in time
for a film's release while this
announcement doesn't mean a return to
those times thank God it does heavily
imply future DC games could utilize
Renditions of characters featured in its
films what do you think of the big
change to The Witcher remake are you
excited for a new Starship Troopers game
let us know in the comments and we'll
see you here for more Gamespot news
foreign